[Music]
you've been broken up for a little while
in retrospect what do you think about
everything that went down I'm in a good
place if it took me a while to get there
um I respect grant recognizing that we
were in two different places
and we just weren't a good fit for each
other at the time are you guys in
communication at all we do not talk
there's definitely not a chance for us
to get back together after this um he
seems to be in a really good place right
now so anything dramatic happened that
led to the break-up or led to your
thoughts about things now since the
break-up just I think I've seen things
that I don't really care for that I
would never want to go through that
again what do you feel like you learned
from the break-up it's like almost like
a death but uh I've learned a lot I I'm
proud of myself for how far I've come in
the last six months and um I think I've
learned a lot about relationships and
just what I need to do in them to be
better are you ready for love again yes
yes - yeah I am ready for love I know
what I want I know that I want to be
with someone and the stading stuff it's
hard where's where's the ring in my
bedroom would you guys ever do another
season whether it be paradise whether it
be the bachelor bachelorette I would be
the bachelor in our beef I've always
hung around guys so I that's easy for me
it's being around so many girls that I
have the trouble how'd you do another
season of Parana no I feel like I have
PTSD from that if I went on there like I
got engaged last time I'd be stepping
down I don't know it's probably not
dating anybody right now I'm not I'm
very single I don't know what I'm
looking for I can tell you this I don't
want to find it on television show
anymore would you date anyone in the
bachelor world without cameras like DUI
on anyone oh I don't totally would but
no what are you my eye on this
[Music]
you